[Music]
this is Patricia Napier Fitzpatrick
how are you Patricia nice to see you
look at you what a honey money huh all
right what are we doing we are going to
cover a few social graces if you don't
mind I mind all of this handshakes are
appropriate for most senior government
officials it's always best to let them
take the initiative in extending the
hand for a shake and then you touch look
first you touch here and then you wait
wait wait and one no no no what no one
no you be Kim Jeong
all right okay don't let go like this
and then go no no so you're gonna face
heart to heart belly button to belly
button now your Putin's hey Blair oh
yeah I love you so much no I don't think
so so let's talk about right I just your
white shirts are perfect baby's pure
white the white race so I would
recommend you button your top button dig
well that's not right perfect
no the top button in the top holes I
always put it in the wrong hole now
let's look look in the mirror look how
much nicer that looks who's that weird
guy a great impression you make when
you're a jacket look at this who's this
guy then where's that guy always that
what's happening who is he sir that's
you it's you it's gonna be okay
it's you in the mirror oh that's perfect
look at that I just want to make one
recommendation the ties should come to
the middle of your belt buckle I think
they'll know because you've told them
many times please give me a break
well where's that just try and focus
you're the president excuse me shall we
dine could you find South Africa on this
man everybody knows that oh man the
napkin you fold it in half and the open
part goes toward the table what am i
what am i I'm my dad at his meetings mr.
president right are you going to
embarrass the United States by not
knowing how to handle these things no
I'm gonna embarrass the United States by
siding up to me Oh Nazis all right good
for you so far in South Africa please
okay it was south is it this no what is
that
touch the logo on the globe waiter get
over here you idiot human garbage
president we call the weights death with
a little finger up mr. president how
about this like this just just a simple
hand gesture what about do we want
saluting no okay please not this can I
go no that's all sides black power yell
Adler the same all sides let's practice
what we learn okay you see and then
you're ruining the steak with ketchup
all right this is
so much blood whoa who's that
there's a ghost in a mirror
and he spelled with a and he speaks to
me through the mirror
and it says find the way to destroy as
many people as possible
I hate the man in the mirror because he
knows my secrets I have a recommendation
right get rid of the mirrors get rid of
the mirrors
[Music]
Paul yes sir
you know mine
[Music]
I understand yes master
whatever you want most